what's going on reject nation greg here
this is gonna be the first movie
reaction
ever to put up on the youtube channel
i'm excited to do this because this is a
movie that i've been
wanting to watch for such a long time
everyone in my inner circle has seen it
but me
because it's halloween i was like you
know what it's time to finally watch
mid samar or midsummer i i don't know
really don't know much about this movie
i hear it's kind of weird but i'm
excited to finally watch this and also
share my experience
with all of you first things first i
want to give a thank you to eric over at
nerd chronic please give this guy
a follow because he has helped us out
with this channel countless times and i
imagine editing reaction highlights for
a movie reaction
is quite a it's a it's a [ __ ] i imagine
it to be a [ __ ] so if you guys end up
liking this reaction please hit that
like button click the subscribe
notification bell this is youtube so
obviously can't show the whole movie so
this is going to be reaction highlights
full length reaction watch along where
you sync up with the time code will be
over
at our patreon page for midsummer and
over there we cover
so many tv shows we're at the same tier
we have the option for either reaction
highlights or watch along
i really do appreciate everyone who's
gone and shown their support for the
channel
hopefully you guys have been liking the
content over there as well helps keep
this channel alive in a time where
youtube keeps
changing up their guidelines and
monetization protocols so really does
mean a lot either way
excited to do this can't wait let's
swing into action people
[Music]
i feel like there's already a lot of
clues
that i i need to latch on to
this is like me and jaby coway
how's the sister situation
um well damn she's good she's good
i'm sure it's fine yeah she does this
every other day danny and only because
you let her
well they don't let her she's bipolar i
know but
it's still just another obvious ploy for
attention just like every other panic
attack should get
he's gonna die in this movie isn't he i
love you all right
bye what a very real conversation
what did your sister write just some
ominous [ __ ] like she always does
and it's had a van
i used to be on a van
what if i regret it later and i can't
get her back you don't want her back i
might
yo okay poulter's in this and don't
forget about all the swedish women you
can impregnate in june okay guys
don't forget about all the swedish
milkmaids
oh so then she should call her therapist
and not you it's literally abuse
she's abusing me he's literally abused
hey oh my
danny god babe
what
oh is she dead
this is a fun movie
wow talk about a yellow production
design
[Music]
what
oh whoa this is not what i thought
wow
jesus christ
[Laughter]
oh now you should break up with her she
should break up with her right now
that'd be great timing
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh god
oh let's look at these paintings
what kind of women did arie oster date
we're in for a movie people
there's a lot of symbolism that's gonna
make sense later huh
it's one of those movies i was just
gonna go to that party for 45 minutes
but you just keep sleeping oh no come
with me
[Music]
i wasn't sleeping anyway
i think he wanted to go alone yeah
they're all coming to visit my home in
helsinki
sweden oh yeah
i mean we were talking about it we were
thinking about it
i'm probably not gonna go but yeah we
were talking about it oh this is so
uncomfortable
i wasn't keeping it from you you already
have a ticket
i'm sorry
man the acting in this is so real
i really think we should just leave no
no no no no please please please i'm not
i'm not trying to attack you
i'm not really feels like you are well
then i well then i'm sorry i'm so i just
got confused i'm sorry i
hey please come on can you come this
character goes to therapy
she goes to therapy that's an
interesting symbol
yeah we're taught to ruin the alphabet
so
whoa who's that one that's last year's
may queen
beautiful oh
you're gonna beat this year's queen i
was so very sorry to hear about
your loss oh what happened i mean i
i lost my parents too so i kind of have
some ideas uh-oh
i'm sorry no no i'm sorry no
i'm gonna just go to the bathroom thank
you
wow what a transitional shot
that was very impressive and
of course really sad what she's going
through
how long is the drive about four hours
oh my god
i really want will poultry to die
i have not missed it perfect timing by
the way we
we just took these five minutes ago yeah
i haven't even started coming up yet
[ __ ] it let's just take it now right
yeah yeah great
oh she she should not take sure she she
really shouldn't
guys i'm gonna wait for danny so you
just go ahead oh man you are creating
such confidence
we can't take them at different times
they'll be totally separate trips
you know what it's fine it's fine i'm
it's i'm ready no
it's okay
oh she's gonna have a [ __ ] nightmare
isn't she
whoa
you're like my real actual family
danny
shouldn't i brought the word family
who is that
[Music]
no
man it does look beautiful to be out
there though
[Music]
and let our nine-day feast commence
[Music]
school
i'm like concerned about every little
thing that are swallowing
who's that who are these
who are these new set of characters
we're cutting around to
that's what i do before i start
recording reactions
happy birthday
oh wow oh my gosh pele
it's just something i do for birthdays
maybe it's not appropriate no
dude she's gonna become like queen of
the village or something
kristen forgot anyways this is amazing
thank you
oh you forgot no no no no i
forgot to remind him and it's it's not
his fault it's
how long have you two been together oh
geez
um just over three and a half years
four years and he forgot her
birthday what's that building over there
it's uh like a sacred temple but no
one's allowed in there
let me show you where we sleep well we
gotta see that temple before the movie
is done
so we're just gonna ignore the bed it's
a bear
it's a bear wow
[Music]
okay yeah
sure why not good story that's a great
story
now we're gonna make up for it you can
sing happy birthday
all right scissors
use those scissors to shut that baby up
uh okay
you know other than a few suspicious
paintings and some
you know random animal stuff it looks
pretty nice over here
[Music]
i would love to grow old to be as happy
as these people
are they gonna kill them are they gonna
kill them
which keep expecting the worst [ __ ] to
happen
this movie just has this like
percolating tension throughout
there's something bad's going to happen
something that's going to happen you
just wait guys
oh that was so gross
her face
you really should give your american
friends who you're probably gonna oh my
goodness
did he pencil down there he went live
[Music]
why did he pencil down
[Music]
oh my god
has just reached the end of their
horrigan life cycle
and you need to understand it as a great
joy for them
yes gramps looked like he was having a
grand little time there
it does no good dodging lashing back at
the
i think you directed conversation to her
i am
so sorry i didn't warn you better
it's so sorry it works it's really
simple
you'll be a couple of old people they're
going gonna jump off a cliff and kill
themselves
yo all things considered danny you
handle that [ __ ] like a champ
i don't know why but you did that was
[ __ ] gross
so believe me when i tell you that i
know what it's like because i
do i really really do
okay but this is like brand new for her
to see like people just committing
suicide where everyone embraced me
swept me up and i was raised by a
community that doesn't bigger overwatch
theirs and what's not theirs by a family
a real family this guy kind of looks
like jack courtney
which everyone deserves how do you
become part of the family you deserve
daddy do you feel held by him
does he feel like home to you oh god
oh god
there's something funny about it
what what
oh this is [ __ ]
this is dream
it's gotta be a dream right it's gotta
be a nightmare
is tied to all of our dead it's a dead
tree though
it's dead yeah yeah i know but it's
important to us i just had to pee
that uh john drew him to the train
station and after
uh simon gets dropped off he's sending
the truck
back for you what yeah you will meet him
uh
there oh don't fall for this so they've
just gone
they've left me just now connie there
was no room in the truck
yet it is coming right oh my god
do you know um have you seen simon
anywhere
yes he was driven to the station did you
not say goodbye
no no i didn't but uh that's okay
it's okay oh thank you
um she's so beautiful is that
is that simon the reading uh this
iteration
is being written by reuben
uh hey it's uh disabled
since birth can i take a photograph
what absolutely not okay sorry
absolutely not
who was that did you hear that did you
guys hear that
has anyone seen connie
i think mark saw her earlier her
boyfriend called the landline from the
train station and called connie down
she begged our part and i drove her to
meet him
i would love it if that's actually all
true
i don't think you're supposed to eat
ahead of time right
oh my god it's a human person isn't it
oh he's going to have something in there
is that a [ __ ] pube ew let's just
stay here
yeah a pubic hair
wow the way they've been pulling focus
on this whole shot is crazy
i'll be back i guess she's gonna show me
man i like this guy
i actually don't want him to die
oh dude
what the [ __ ] mark the [ __ ] are you
doing close the door we're not supposed
to be in here
what happened to him
did they cut off his there is gentle
mutilation
what the [ __ ]
they took him to the train station where
is your friend josh
i know uh we have no idea
he and your other friend they both
disappeared
the same day he came to bed with us and
when we woke up he was gone and if he
did take that book i just pray you
understand
we don't associate his friends of his or
collaboration
dick okay
oh oh god here we go
[Music]
welcome to the family danny
[Music]
she's having a good time
so who talks first you talk first thing
i just have to say i have no idea where
josh is
and i can swear to that on my mother's
life how do you feel about
maya i think i
ate one of her pubic hairs sounds
probably right
oh god he's so
nonchalant about it i think i ate one of
her pubic hairs
oh danny you're pulling it off
look at you you're so natural you belong
danny
no danny survive
no survive danny win the dance
competition i don't speak swedish
[Music]
foreign
danny you are our
may queen me yes
why you won
what does that mean way to go daddy
[Music]
[Music]
way to go danny
it's just a typical hollywood fish out
of water story
what's going on
to our may queen
i have no clue what the hell's happening
this
is truly a weird movie go
ghosts have sex i have
later a path of flower petals for you to
follow
which will lead into the vagina
soon reminds me of roy
pamela's ex-fiance
on the office
what the [ __ ] not the way i imagine this
going down
[Music]
what's that it's not for us
oh she kind of knows she's all
[Music]
sad
oh queen oh man
wow they're they're great at the shadow
game they really are
oh snap he been gardened
in
holy moses
what did they do
is he still breathing
oh full growth
oh this just does not end
as an offering to our father we will
today
surrender nine human lives
as horga takes so horga also gives
and to pella who has brought
new blood and our new may queen
you will today be honored for your
unclouded
intuition and so
for our ninth offering
well these are the candidates for the
ninth and final offering
jesus christ
get some wicker man vibes
wowie
what was with that bear
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
oh my god
you're so messed up man can't believe
they did that to that bear
you guys just came here looking to have
a good trip and you didn't even want
danny to come
and now danny's walking out on top
[Music]
this is something man
them feeling the pain with them huh
oh
oh oh
oh she's looking really happy
ugh
you
okay so that
was a lot to digest
i'm gonna need to see some youtube
videos on this to me it was like a
breakup movie wasn't it it's kind of
like a breakup movie
you're hopping back and forth between
danny and christian's perspective
primarily danny's perspective obviously
occasionally you break perspective to
see some of the other information being
learned it's like occasionally you break
perspective
from danny or christian but usually one
of them is around and the perspectives
seem to go in and out and then the whole
time it's kind of just alluding
from the very beginning about them
breaking up there's uncomfortable
tensions the friends don't really
accept them as a couple they definitely
don't accept danny
i mean right down to when that couple
from london was there and they're
talking about their engagement and he's
avoiding it they might have been
together longer than that british couple
this whole thing is as they're
experiencing the harga
experience together even though it's on
the same field in the same location
they're having two very different
experiences where
their woes are causing
strife and uncomfortableness for the
friends they can't keep up with it
they're drifting apart
slowly with danny you know you set her
up with this as
this character who's struggling
emotionally because she's already has
obviously some
of her own mental health conditions she
sees a psychologist she takes lorazepam
she has anxiety her sister has mental
illness issues obviously so she starts
off with this very devastating
death within her like several family
members the most important
so she doesn't really have a family you
know it seemed kind of obvious i don't
know why i really didn't know anything
about this movie before going into it i
heard some stuff about like some animal
cruelty that's why i wanted to now watch
this with my girlfriend because she's
uh can't handle animal cruelty so you
had the whole thing with a bear and like
that would have been a big no-no
situation so i was like okay maybe i
think i said something when i was
watching it about how she'll become
queen or should be up on that
that wall at some point and i guess in
some way like
there's something about that ritual that
stands out to me when the old people
were you know jumping off the cliff and
how she was reacting like yes she walked
away
eventually started crying and was
feeling very disturbed by the whole
situation
as one would be and even her emotional
reaction
is different from the guys who she
showed up with even
like the well poulter's mark character
he
was even like oh i missed out on the
best part you know like this to them
seems to be a fascination a study
something that doesn't ultimately push
them away
at the same time though when she was
watching it her reaction
seemed to be kind of like she was a
there was an alluring quality like she
was drawn to it
so it's like this this version of it
that kind of makes me think
of her family had a violent death and
then her
new family has sort of a violent
beginning i i think like it's the
direction of
those themes seem to make sense to me
it's like a breakup movie she doesn't
have a family she's finding a new family
there's a lot of hallucination stuff
dream-like sequences that are occurring
in this film
like a lot of horror movies i imagine
not all of it can be taken in the most
literal sense maybe right down to its
closing image like i'm not sure what to
make of that closing moment
like she comes into her own she gets
this act of vengeance
the people that have mistreated her this
person she gave four years of her life
to who
is behind her back really didn't want to
be with her and even
cheats on her you know there's things
about the the whole
mimicking of emotions like how this
whole
harga group acts as one
unit when they're being set on fire
they're they're screaming like kind of
in pain or
or when danny is belching out these
tears this
agony and they start mimicking her and
in a way
it's like they're connecting to her
right that's what i think i'm supposed
to get from it they're
they're connecting to her in that moment
it seems like throughout this whole
story she's just sort of been isolated
and she's not understood and no one
really connects with her not even her
own boyfriend and then here she's
finding a real connection real family i
mean the one who's connecting her most
out of all the guys is
don't want to say peli i wish i watched
this with subtitles
peli uh the the swedish guy who's part
of the group who
who brought them over there like he
seemed out of any of the dude more than
her boyfriend was the you remember her
birthday he was the one who really
seemed to go out of
his way to identify with her like about
his family dying his parents dying and
saying i get how you feel so this
in a weird way is a is a giant breakup
movie it's what
what it was under the disguise of like a
wicker man cult
film uh which i do find fascinating like
yes everything up it's very different
from hereditary and i
i love hereditary i liked it a lot the
first time i saw the second time i
watched it i loved it even more
tonally the way it's captured everything
about it even
even you know like hereditary seem to
have some if you haven't seen him
assuming you've seen it
uh it seemed to have uh took the
approach of oh yeah
there's actual like supernatural things
happening
whereas in here a lot of that is left
very ambiguous
at the at the end of it all you know i
walk away thinking that it's not
actual you know literal spiritual things
occurring this is their
beliefs it's the culture i didn't walk
away thinking that this is actual
you know like literal spiritual things
that are uh
occurring yet there's still an ambiguous
angle to it that it possibly could be
yes because it is like a mood piece in a
lot of ways and it is
sort of capitalizing on the mood of a
distance growing between
you know danny and christian who i
thought did wonderful
jobs on their performances but florence
pugh my god the number one thing
i heard about this movie was florence
pugh's performance
and very early on it is in that scene
where she's talking with
like yes she has like very early on the
the big grieving moments the the loss of
devastation
i don't know what it is about arya astor
who likes to write about
you know emotionally devastated
women it's his cup of tea before pelly
talks
talks to them at the apartment about
like how she's going to be going
to sweden with them and just the way
she's reacting to everything every
bit of her her moments here it's such a
lived-in performance from the very
opening scene to the last
you know there is something that is i
guess cathartic by the end just because
of how a lot of them didn't treat her
terribly directly to her face but as an
audience peering in and seeing
christian's perspective a lot of time
you see that they have no respect for
her they really don't give a [ __ ] about
her
and he does cheat on her in the end in a
very terrible awkward way all the acting
is really good
uh in here and the the mood and
environment was just
shocking the color palette was
absolutely beautiful like the
cinematography on here
excellent the thing that really stood
out to me the most here
like yes there's some gorgeous moving
shots there's some gorgeous symmetry you
know it's a very bright film and i love
how this film starts off
so dark like it actually threw me for a
loop because
i i remember that from the trailer being
like this is a really brightly lit movie
and then in the first like before they
go to sweden it's very dark and then by
the end of it
amidst the violent acts and and all the
craziness that has ensued with getting
danny's smile at the end
that very unsettling smile everything is
so
bright so she's like
part a participant in all this she's the
queen of it
while there's such a sinister menacing
feeling yet her world is
brighter i i think that's cool i did get
a little bit of a headache though
i did it start it start i don't know if
it's just i haven't done like a movie
reaction before and you have these
lights here and i was looking at this
i'm sitting here you normally when i
watch a movie you know i'm
like you guys i'm especially if i'm home
chilling on the couch probably eating
food or something in
here i got the headphones on i'm
listening to all the noise and the
screaming and the chaos in my ears
so yeah in terms of a mood piece that
was great i thought it was a little
funnier than i expected it to be too
like there are parts where it seems
intentionally funny there are parts
where it's
uncomfortably funny the violence is
certainly shocking
it's uncomfortable like it's i wouldn't
say i was
terrified or really scared but it's a
very uncomfortable movie and it's a
different kind of horror
it's not you know jump scare or
obviously i wouldn't expect that out of
this movie
it's not demonic like horror it's a
different kind of social anxiety
that it's sort of preying on then it
gets a lot more literal with
things that are what i thought was cool
about the approach
of it too you know the word cult stan is
short for culture it might not sound
like the best words to differentiate it
but it didn't seem like diabolical evil
cult
even though from the american
perspective yeah it does
just i think from most people's
perspective not just american
perspective but most
most of the world this would seem like
evil and sick yet the way
the the uh i'm already forgetting it
hagar
hogar uh hagar the way the the the way
they're
portrayed in the way the performances
emulate
they never seem to be like evil grinning
malicious people they they do seem like
oh this is just a certain kind of
culture this is just a certain kind of
people their perspectives on it don't
ever seem to
deviate into ruthless evil
their actions that we're seeing are
you know the way we're reacting to it
and feeling it but the way they're
captured and the way the performances
are done
they never seem to be like look how much
we
feast upon the evil you know it was
definitely executed in uh
in a way i wasn't expecting i i guess i
like it yeah i do i i i i liked it quite
a bit
actually pleasantly surprised by that i
mean it's a lot to take in
feel like i'm gonna have to watch some
youtube videos better explain some of
the symbolism like there are things with
the flowers that i feel like i'm not
quite latching on to that are obviously
very metaphorical
something about birth or new life
is what i'm assuming like even by the
end where she's just drenched in flowers
like there was a part of it where the
way she was moving or if how heavy the
flowers were weighing on her that kind
of seemed like a caterpillar
and the way she was moving in the body
language i don't know if that's
intentional but it sort of felt like oh
caterpillar that will morph into a
butterfly being bloomed
but yeah having a brand new life so she
could finally fly and i i guess she's
gonna stay here and delight in this
world
a lot of vulnerable stuff here a lot of
shocking things
very unsettling very uncomfortable glad
i saw it this is one to ruminate on i
don't know how i could possibly sum up
all my thoughts
uh right now because it is a reaction
it's usually the kind of movie i'd want
like a day to separate
myself from so that way i could let
things settle in and be like you know
i've digested this
and here's how i feel but transition
shots are great
everything about it i thought was really
well executed i could see how this is
not everyone's cup of tea
it's a very specific kind of movie yeah
i don't know it's
it's experimental and i just love the
idea of like doing a breakup movie but
in the
with the backdrop of like a wicker man
cult-like film and that whole thing with
the bear
you know it seemed very wicker man
homage
honestly i haven't seen the original
liquor man i'm talking about the nick
cage version
so yeah but anywho mid samar
here we are ha that rhymed tara car
par far jar lars and the real girl
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell please let me know
your thoughts about mitsumar down below
if you enjoyed this movie reaction hey
let me know
if uh you want to see more movie
reactions big thanks again to eric over
at nerd chronic for editing this
last but not least patron of the day
shout out
i want to shout out scuba steve face off
everything
i know about you especially one who
likes to graffiti
artistic and just the way how
relationships can kind of go for you
if there's anyone that i know that could
definitely fit in
with this swedish group it's you buddy
take that as a compliment i really think
that if you were part of the swedish
group you might not be
a woman but i bet they'd crown you
queen and i bet all these swedish women
would just
fall at your feet you're a good looking
guy
you like horror feel like you're
accepting of other people's beliefs
join the harga group because i think you
would be a perfect fit you want to be
like all these other dumb americans
you'd be like i'm into this
i'm into this i don't know if we should
hang out in person considering the fact
that i think you would fit in so well
with the hardware group but i'm glad to
keep talking to you online i'm just
kidding about it i love you man i hope
you're doing well hope you're
catching up on some awesome horror
movies during this halloween season
since i know horror is your favorite
genre of film i haven't heard from you
in a while hopefully i can hear back
from you soon
take care bud happy halloween
[Music]
you